-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're watching us.
Thank you very much.
Guys, I want to say congrats
to the Kansas City Chiefs
and the Philadelphia Eagles
on advancing to Super Bowl LVII.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yeah, to all Chiefs fans,
I want to say congratulations.
To all the Eagles fans,
I want to say good morning.
You could tell Philly partied
hard last night because today,
the Rocky statue is holding up
Tylenol and a Gatorade.
Of course, everyone in
Kansas City is just as pumped.
This is the Chiefs'
third Super Bowl appearance
in the last four years.
Even Tom Brady is like, "Hey,
give someone else a chance."
Everyone is excited for
the Super Bowl.
Half the country
will root for the Chiefs,
half will root for the Eagles,
while Rob Lowe
is still rooting for the NFL.
I want that hat.
He'll lend that to me.
I want to borrow that.
Meanwhile, before becoming
coach of the Chiefs,
Andy Reid was head coach of
the Eagles for 14 years.
Here's a photo of him
then versus now.
He looks exactly the same.
I don't know
how this is possible,
but somehow, Andy Reid
is the Paul Rudd of the NFL.
He looks great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And get this --
for the first time,
two brothers will be
facing off in the Super Bowl.
Yep, Chiefs tight end
Travis Kelce
is playing against his brother,
Eagles center Jason Kelce.
Here they are. Yeah.
And this is cute.
Their mom, Donna, goes to as
many of their games as possible,
and she even has a jersey that's
half Travis', half Jason's.
Look at this.
Is that the best?
[ Applause ]
When asked about
the Super Bowl, Donna said...
Then she said...
Finally, she said...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tell it like it is.
What a proud mom.
Switching gears,
some political news.
In a new video,
former president Trump
said that if re-elected,
he would protect the U.S.
from World War III by building
an impenetrable dome
over the country.
[ Laughter ]
Then Trump said,
"We're going to build a dome
and make Mars pay for it."
Trump was like, "Just think of
a dome as basically
a wall with a comb-over.
That's all.
It's a wall with a comb-over."
Meanwhile, this weekend,
Trump was on his plane
and speaking to reporters
when he said
that Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis
is acting like
he didn't shut down his state
during the pandemic,
even though he did.
Watch this.
"Yeah, it's very hard
to rewrite history.
Anyway, do you want to hear
more about how
I won the 2020 election?"
Speaking of DeSantis, I saw that
he's actively preparing for
a possible presidential run,
and he hasn't landed on
an official slogan yet,
but he's trying a few out.
First, there's...
Next, there's...
And, finally...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That could work.
That's interesting.
Well, some TV news.
CNN just suffered its worst week
of ratings in nine years.
So to get ratings up, they've
introduced a new program --
"CNN Presents New Year's Eve
Every Day.
I think I found
the solution to this problem.
I think they need to add
one more person to their panel.
Yeah.
There's 15 people on there.
Well, this is wild.
A 25-year-old hacker allegedly
stole the personal data
of everyone in Austria
and tried to sell it online.
Yep, every single Austrian
got hacked.
It's so bad, the country is
actually leaning into it.
Check out this ad I just saw.
-Come visit Austria, the country
of beautiful classical music,
delicious pastry,
und Guenther, age 64,
who recently Googled,
"What is MILF'?"
Walk the same streets as
Beethoven, Freud, und Klaus,
who just bought 13 cat toys,
but he doesn't have a cat.
[ Buzzer ]
Here is his credit-card number.
Use it.
Visit the Hofburg Palace,
the Vienna opera house, or Hans.
He lives at
536 Lindenstrasse Road.
The key is under the mat.
Hurry! He gets home at 6:00!
Austria --
your identity will get stolen.
Ja!"
-Isn't that --
Interesting commercial, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
They gave out the man's address.
-That's great. That's fantastic.
-Hey, guys,
it's National Meat Week.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yeah!
-This reminds me of all
the great Meat Week specials
on TV when I was a kid.
They actually showed a rerun
of one of my favorites tonight.
Take a look at this.
-Really?
♪♪
-Trick or meat!
-I got a beef sirloin.
-I got a smoked ham.
-I got a lamb shank.
-I got Arby's.
-"Your Cholesterol is
Alarmingly High, Charlie Brown"
will return after
these messages.
-Oh, I love that cartoon.
Guys, I heard about
a New Zealand-bound plane
that took off from Dubai,
flew for 13 hours,
then had to turn around and land
back at the same airport.
The pilot started
his announcement by saying,
"Okay, so, don't be mad..."
Meanwhile, in America,
we're all like,
"Hey, at least it took off.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Finally, you guys, tomorrow
is the last day of January,
so I thought it would be nice to
give a little recap
of the entire month.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ It's the end of January ♪
♪ What a big month
for Prince Harry ♪
♪ He wrote a wrote a book,
and did you see this ♪
♪ He got frostbite... ♪
-On his penis.
-♪ Congress voted
for a speaker ♪
♪ It turned out
to be a squeaker ♪
♪ McCarthy said,
"I got this, bro" ♪
♪ Then he lost... ♪
-14 times in a row.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Poor George Santos
under fire ♪
♪ Everyone says
that he's a liar ♪
♪ His résumé
is not so clean ♪
♪ Plus, he used to be... ♪
-A drag queen?!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. [ Chuckles ]
♪ Biden, Trump,
and Pence got caught ♪
♪ with houses
full of secret docs ♪
♪ How the heck
could you forget? ♪
♪ Joe kept them next to... ♪
-My Corvette.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ The robot movie "M3GAN"
crushed ♪
♪ And people loved
"The Last of Us" ♪
♪ "Avatar," it didn't bomb ♪
♪ It made us all say... ♪
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Eagles-Chiefs
Super Bowl ♪
♪ Niners, Bengals
watch from home ♪
♪ Can't talk trash from
your couch, gotta... ♪
-Know your role
and shut your mouth!
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
-♪ It was the first month
of the year ♪
♪ We all got through it
without beer ♪
♪ But February isn't dry ♪
♪ So let's get trashed
on Valentine's ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪